on va faire une interview prise de tête
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est bien dans je ne sais pas ce que va
être le gage
c'est le cas je sais pas quel prix je
leur ai payé mais il a cherché après
cher possible de l'apec tu as ce soir-là
prend des vacances même qui va chier
manos vient alors à se prendre un peu la
tête sur des sujets sérieux julien clerc
est ce que vous êtes favorable au droit
de vote pour les immigrés j'avais averti
ses prises de tête oui oui même si des
gens qui payent des impôts en france non
pas le voilà ça c'est pas normal
penser que les assassins d'enfants
mérite la peine de mort alors ça
évidemment c'était c'est une question
que je me pose c'est parce que j'ai j'ai
fait une chanson moi là dessus sur la
peine de mort est évidemment c'est un
débat un terrible et je devrais vous
répondre au nom puisque jeu quand on est
contre la peine de mort on est contre la
peine de mort est un temps quand on a
des enfants
oui on a envie de de penser le contraire
voilà mais enfin disons que je suis
contre la peine de mort je continue de
l'être si l'un de vos proches souffrait
d'un mal incurable est-ce que vous soyez
favorables à l'euthanasie si la personne
en expriment le besoin
évidemment si elle le mentionne si elle
le demande c'est le réclament oui
l'avortement mais l'avortement je suis
évidemment pour l'avortement
simplement je crois que c'est à dire 2
par exemple je crois qu'il faut essayer
de tout faire pour en arriver là
voilà mais sinon c'est un droit c'est
une nécessité c'est savez de même moi
j'ai toujours pensé que c'était les
femmes qui décident et d'avoir les
enfants et bien ils peuvent décider
aussi le contraire en avoir ça c'est un
droit absolument qu'ils ne devraient pas
discuter
est ce que vous êtes favorable à
l'adoption d'enfants par dés couples
homosexuels
je pense que les enfants ont besoin
d'amour mais en même temps c'est vrai
que on peut réfléchir à ça on peut on
peut j'ai vu des films magnifiques déjà
enfin les très jolis films d'actualités
là dessus je réfléchirai avant mais si
vous me demandez de mettre un bulletin
dans l'urne je crois que finirait par
dire oui je suis si tu pensé que c'est
un crime contre soi même c'est un droit
je pense qu'il faut vachement de courage
moi je suis cité mais ce n'est quand la
peine de marche pas pourquoi on pourrait
se l'appliquer à soi n'ont maintenant
plus de dix ans le suicide c'est quand
quelqu'un celui-ci c'est qu'il est trop
mal
il ya des choses qui ne peut plus
regarder ce qu'il ne peut plus vivre des
choses qui ne en payant des mots simples
de la langue française qui ne supportent
plus tout simplement décision pour les
autres nous notre pas là dedans on n'a
pas à juger ça vous croyez pas en dieu
vous mais j'aimerais bien par moments ça
serait plus facile en particulier dans
votre dans votre questionnaire quand on
croit en dieu on a d un chemin tout
tracé
non malheureusement alors je jeu j'aime
beaucoup les gens qui croient qu'une
union qui ont la foi
en même temps j'ai été heureux de
heureux j'étais je ne nie pas j'ai été
élevé là dedans on même si on ne
pratiquait pas beaucoup enfin en
d'autres termes j'ai été heureux de
maria l'église quand le moment était
venu de 2,2 me marier je pars à l'église
tous les dimanches que je suis issu de
cette culture langue et j'admire les
gens qui croient mois malheureusement
vous y croyez pas alors c'est un truc
bien vis j'y crois pas et même quand
l'avion commence un peu à bouger comme
ça j'ai d'une croix toujours pas quoi
oui et non c'est à dire non mais c'est
vrai je vais
ça serait se renier aussi se met à prier
tout vous êtes en ligne
j'essaie toujours les j'essaie d'être
cohérent un peu près égale vous dans
l'avion bouge pas il vient de sortir de
là que tu vas mourir c'est l est a
priori un exercice pour faire un peu
hésitant j'ai dans un avion fait voilà
oui c'est le test anciennes pièces de
l'avion qu'il bouge avec ce n'est pas
non plus dans la viande inventer son
pari avait pris l'avion
oui là encore c'est pascal lui disait tu
te mets à genoux tu pries et un jour tu
croiras c'est autre chose on bouge pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien alors justement continuer à se
prendre la tête là imaginez vous faites
un enfant une fille mais vous en faites
en a une autre fille alors est ce que
vous demandez d'apporter ça dépend si
j'ai dix si j'ai 18 ans et que j'ai pas
de thunes pour le faire vivre et que je
sais que j'ai des problèmes dans la vie
j'ai pas de pas de boulot pas l'intérêt
50 ans était milliardaire à leur tour
être au milieu d'un giga d'accouchement
ce canton bien faire jouer votre mère
est atteinte d'une maladie incurable et
vous demandent l'euthanasie
oui non si moi je pourrais pas le faire
parce que c'est ma mère mais je
comprendrais qu'elles veulent si elles
souffrent ou que veut arrêter ça vous
laisserez les toubibs le faire si elle
le demande si elle me regarde et me dit
où il faut trouver une solution ben je
parle à la gare d affaires se regarder à
s'offrir quoi moi je n'ai toujours pas
mr sylla vrai toujours jouer je voyais
avec tes pieds dans la boue fait
toujours le sourire si la voie dans un
lit d'hôpital et qu'elle demande un truc
je pense que ça peut être entre
guillemets humain de craquer je pense
quand même parce que si pas laisser
souffrir sa mère c'est quand même un
type type a violé et tué trois gamines
de
11 ans peine de mort pas peine de mort
c'est difficile je suis un peu contre la
peine de mort mais comme si ces méga
mensah se trouve pour allécher tout ça
ouais donc ouais non mais c'est vrai
c'est vrai si si si si ton enfant et que
tu vois quelqu'un qui abusent et un
enfant qui est tout petit enfant que tu
aimes tu peux aller faire des choses de
fou vous avez des amis homosexuels c'est
un jeu de l'esprit qui est en ville ça
qu'ils envisagent qui envisagent
d'adopter un enfant
boulouart conseillé de le faire vous
leur dites que c'est pas bien alors dit
que c'est pas bien
vous croyez en dieu je crois en dieu
si vous tuez différentes façons de prix
ouais si vous deviez choisir une
religion vous choisiriez laquelle
peut-être la religion musulmane parce
qu'elle colle plus avec
avec quand tu veux tout simplement
content représente jésus blond aux yeux
bleus
ouais je suis noir plutôt l'islam bien
répondre brièvement sur des sujets
graves
c'est bien jean marie c'est bien c'est
une des raisons pour lesquelles je vous
admire je sais que vous ne bougez pas
pendant le jingle et vous aussi des
biens êtes vous favorable à la sexualité
hors mariage bah oui parce que on est on
est pas à l'abri et puis il ya des fois
c'est bien d'eux peut-être des fois de
toucher une autre peau une autre paire
de nichons à notre show pinette nos
traders un truc comme ça donc vous êtes
vous êtes favorable à la sexualité hors
mariage sont favorables jeu jj aj set je
suis un pauvre je suis un pauvre eu peur
je pense que fo congolais sans son mari
que dans la veste tu retrouves un
préservatif chaud ça nul de faire une
scène à son mari parce que trompé sa
femme avec un préservatif c'est une
petite bêtise trompé sa femme sans
préservatif c'est une grosse connerie et
donc je dis moi j'ai les couilles en
tout cas de dire bah moi que je pars en
tournée ma femme me prépare ma valise me
mets mes chemises mes chaussettes mais
slip viennent me même petite boîte de
préservatifs et beaucoup je ne trompe
jamais ma femme mais c'est pour le kg de
sabra mot divorce bas
je sais que ça peut arriver et si si
jamais c'est nécessaire bien sûr il faut
il faut le faire en ce qui me concerne
moi j'aime bien l'idée dans ma vie à moi
de mettre marié avec une femme et de ne
jamais la quitter jusqu'à la fin de mes
jours pour moi je trouve que c'est plus
+ samouraï quoi c'est plus
bien est-ce que vous êtes favorable
adoptions d'enfants par dés couples
homosexuels
aulas lance pas la team a fait une heure
au téléphone non non non oui mais non
maintenant je peux développer un petit
peu parce que maintenant il ya un truc
est formidable avec le le pack si jamais
tu dis par exemple que tu es contre le
pacs tu passe pour un homme femme tout
le monde fuit dans son froc on veut pas
être homophobe moi je suis pas à ma
femme vous trouvez peut-être que
l'homosexualité était plus sexy du temps
où il était sulfureux c'était plus sexy
jean genet que les petits couples qui
vont faire les courses ensemble chez
auchan de matin non je dis simplement
que la république
n'importe quel gouvernement nous en tout
cas la république en général n'a pas
validé ce n'est pas le travail de la
république de valider une tendance
sexuelle ce n'est pas un troisième sexe
d'être un succès ça concerne d'ailleurs
à 80% les hommes déjà faut le dire c'est
pas un truc qui concerne les zones
habitables et simplement j'ai dit en
déconnant à tous mes copains homosexuel
je le redis les jours on n'en dormira un
enfant tissé en lui disant et le prince
charmant embrassa le prince charmant
il ne se marièrent bas ils n'eurent pas
d'enfant puisqu'il se bourrer r le cul
alors jours mais ils vécurent heureux je
suis dit je n'ai rien je n'ai rien du
tout vraiment encore une fois je le
répète parce que c'est hyper dangereux
de parler de ça parce que c'est la
vieille crainte d'être de se retrouver
homophobes non le trou de balle c'est
une zone érogène formidable et tout
quand on ne passe un peu le doigt sur le
trop de balles c'est génial ça peut même
des fois de sauver d'une demi mal donc
moi je suis pas du tout ennemi du
dialogue on voudrait bien mais ça c'est
fait alors toujours qu'est ce qui arrive
je voulais la réaction de vidy c'est ce
que vous êtes pour l'adoption d'enfants
par les couples homosexuels
bien sûr et puis n'est-ce pas à la
république a décidé de quoi que ce soit
je dis on parle d'amour quand on parle
d'enfants à l'affût de la république qui
dit non mais non pas un nouvel enfant on
en a à [ __ ] de la république la
république elle n'a pas défendre une
tendance aurait une sans jean richard un
moment je vais pas me poser la question
est ce que la république est d'accord à
ce que le bon dieu est d'accord à ce que
est ce que machin est d'accord on s'en
fout la république sont les enfants on
s'en fout un enfant il devait trouver un
train avant à vie doit être élevée en
train d'arriver une femme c'est quand
même le mieux pour moi c'est là c'est la
normalité
parce que je dis pas que des tendances
assez anormal je dis que c'est une
originalité
encore un cas très dur aussi reconnaître
mieux sac si le gamin il avec deux pas
en compte comme les valises et de mec
2' de fantastique peut-être qu'il a dans
ce cadre précis ça peut être mieux bien
sûr moi je parle pas là on parle de
théories évidemment on est sur le papier
sur le papier je dis que
l'épanouissement d'un enfants élevés par
deux hommes je pense que c'est moins
bien qu'un homme et une femme
j'ai le droit de penser ça comme bien
sûr bien alors jean marie en continu
l'interview prise vas-y vas-y continue
l'avortement pour moi l'âme n'est pas
arrivé dans le foetus avant au moins six
mois et il n'y a pas une destruction
d'une personne c'est certain c'est un
embryon pour ceux qui pensent qu'ils ont
détruit une personne je pense pas que ce
soit le cas ça n'est pas suffisamment
formés d'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'on
peut pas sortir un bébé du ventre de sa
mère à deux mois et le faire vivre parce
qu'il n'a pas d'existence encore
l'euthanasie l'euthanasie je suis contre
parce que je pense que
il faut même si les souffrances sont
terribles je pense qu'il faut les vivre
jusqu'au bout et que comme je crois pas
au hasard encore une fois je pense que
bon il ya 10 à différents cas de figure
il y avait des gens par exemple la
technique peut permettre de rester de
laisser brancher quelqu'un et de le
faire vivre même contre ça veut dire que
naturellement il n'aurait pas vécu et il
serait mort donc après le fait de
débrancher quelqu'un qui a le cerveau
totalement mort c'est très c'est
différent mais je parle l'euthanasie
c'est à dire donner la mort
c'est pas retirer un médicament c'est
différent retirer un truc qui fait vivre
c'est différent de donner la mort mais
donner la mort non la peine de mort pour
les assassins enfants dès qu'on dit le
mot enfant tout le monde a envie de tuer
tout le monde
si on tue ton enfance où tes yeux la
peine devant tu vas pas attendre que les
jurés délibèrent tu vas mettre suscita
un pistolet dans la main tu vas tu
risques de la donner la mort
effectivement dans tous les cas de
figure je peux plus je pourrai jamais
dire que je cautionne la mort est encore
une fois comme le pacs quand c'est la
loi qui décide de dire voilà on va
prendre tel individu et on va le tuer
ouais
cc c'est injouable personne ne peut
voter une loi comme ça en revanche ce
qu'il faut dire c'est que tout le monde
est à peu près d'accord pour tout le
monde mais une grosse majorité des gens
sont d'accord que quand il ya des otages
pris dans un avion tu as des mecs du
gign ils se font avec une paire de
couilles énorme comme ça et qui on rend
hommage d'ailleurs il rentre il canarde
et y tue les mecs et tout le monde dit
bravo
et là il n'ya pas de tribunaux il n'ya
rien du tour décide de la peine de mort
un mec rentrer dans une école barre des
dynamiques comme anaïs rentre on lui met
une balle en citerons rémois j'applaudis
bas on a voté la peine de mort là on est
tous d'accord par quelques trous du cul
qui dit on aurait peut-être pu le garder
en vie mais moi mais moi moi je dis non
parce que moi je dis que si un mec
rentrer dans une maternelle avec un
paquet de dynamite sur lui si ce mec
risque la vie de trente enfants qu'ils
risquent au moins sa vie et personne ne
me contredira en disant que depuis
l'attaqué qui a été fait sur l'avion il
ya plus jamais de détournement il y en
avait
il y en avait 1 tous les six mois il y
en a pu parce que on se dit merde si je
fais ça c'est la mort sûre et certaine
donc je suis partagé entre les deux je
ne la gamme sonnerait pas je ne dirais
pas qu'il faut aller la donner mais en
revanche la loi c'est très très dur
parce que ce qui est écrit encore une
fois c'est exactement le thème de ce
qu'en disait tout à l'heure ce qui est
écrit n'est pas valable
il ya une loi pour chaque situation que
le mec je suis un mec qui piquent trois
pizzas entendu ça ipic
si tu fais trois délits d'un certain
d'un autre certains états des états unis
trois fois le même délit perpétuité
c'était c'est un sketch si je me mets
avec le nom on fait un sketch et dessus
le mec qui piquent trois pizzas y prend
perpétuité il ya un juge avec des mecs
qui sont là le juge il rentre chez lui
dit à sa femme chérie j'ai fait mon
travail aujourd'hui il ya un mais qu'il
avait piqué trois pizzas gmi perpète
et tout le monde regarde dans le plus
grand pays du monde c'est à dire que ce
rôle ilic ont le même cécile prend une
quiche
il échappe
il échappe à perpète il peut quand même
en plus si je mets si jamais ils veulent
les trois pizzas d'un coup elle en
congés les deux pour lui ça il fera
pareil le préjudice est le même pour le
mec il va pas en prison
comment est-ce qu'on peut cautionner les
lois comme ça c'est la loi du coeur qui
fonctionne et c'est comme ça que
j'essaye de répondre à tes [ __ ] de
bordel égalisation des années
la légalisation des drogues douces vous
demande pas si vous êtes d'accord la
légalisation des drogues douces
oui oui bien sûr allons-y et la
libération de maurice papon alors la
libération de maurice papon c'est à
mourir de rire
moi j'aimais bien badinter je laime plus
maintenant un balle à terre il nous dira
papon et les vieux et tout c'est pas
utile de laisser en prison à temps il
les crimes crimes contre l'humanité 1
ce mec président crimes contre
l'humanité il ya crime il ya aussi
l'humanité
ouais non mais oui d'accord mais
seulement ce mec on aurait préféré le
l'enfermer quand il était jeune non m on
l'a eu deux vieux adversaires en leur
ferry vieux et malade on en fait on le
laisse enfermer et en plus j'ai dit que
c'est vachement sympa d'être en prison
vieux et malade
ouais ce qui était à l'infirmerie tu
gâches pathé vaise année c'est mieux
mais ça veut dire quoi de libérer un mec
ça veut dire que bon bah c'est fini non
non non c'est pas possible il faut se
garder en prison à moi je pense qu on le
garde en prison il a failli les juger il
prend des années de prison mexico à
l'histoire
quand un gars s'ils veulent un scooter
on le colle en le collant saison quand
un mec il a il a tué une autre personne
et tout bas on le met en prison aussi et
puis si c'est un homme d'affaires qui
gruge des trucs et bat aussi est le fils
mitterrand comme madame mitterrand elle
dit j'ai payé la rançon la rançon moi
j'aurais demandé 15 millions - la rampa
n'y a pas de rançon le mec on lui
reproche pas l'autre joué les gens dans
le vi mitterrand dire il me regarde avec
de la haine dans les yeux ils te
regardent comme il veut qu est ce que tu
en avant les sites à rien est reproché
il peut être regardée comme ils le
donc bien sûr donc c est donc ce juge
moi je le trouve je trouve génial j'ai
je crois je le trouve génial parce que
même pierre botton j'ai vu une interview
et lui aussi je les trouve formidable
parce que les divas comment il vous a
enfermé vous êtes tout prix et où il dit
ouais mais au bout du compte je pense
qu'il m'a remis sur les sur les rails et
n'a jamais attaqué par quelque chose que
cf
[Applaudissements]
tout le monde nous
bouge pas pendant la guerre le saviez
tout le monde a bougé serge si je remets
le chapeau bougeait pas ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
franchement thierry ça ne dirais pas de
pétanque
[Applaudissements]
oui je suis maso quand même parce qu'il
faut être maso pour maintenance des
appareils
faut quand même avec une mauresque et
des boules ça passe très bien
il faut aimer être soumis pour mettre ça
oui vraiment assez le chapeau de la
soumission à l'est c'est parce qu'on
vous a coiffé bien au mieux ça va mais
cheveux bien donc un thème prise de tfz
prat la wii est ce que vous êtes je sais
pas des questions compliquées c'est
juste votre avis est ce que vous êtes
favorable au divorce
ben oui bien sûr
oui bien sûr ben non mais si la question
se pose si déjà la question se pose
c'est que ça va mais ça ne va pas aller
très bien donc il dévore tout quoi bon
vous êtes favorable au divorce
je suis pas favorable au divorce si les
gens ont déjà ils ont décidé de se
marier et ben s'est imposée favorable
ouais voilà
voici déjà exposé la question c'est oui
est ce que vous êtes favorable à la
fidélité dans le couple
bah ça c'est pareil moi forcément si on
me demande
ben oui pour moi oui pour les autres
c'est ça les regarde les dix mois mahler
l'accord jeudi tout ça non mais c'est le
statu quo jeudi tout à ça veut rien dire
parce qu'avant mais non mais tous
adaptés sacré bat à chaque fois
différent non mais c'est vous qui nous
intéressait oui non mais d'accord mais
même moi voilà y assister par exemple on
peut le mari je détruis depuis dix ans à
quelqu'un et que je l'aimais vraiment
mais qu'en même temps ben en fin on peut
jamais savoir quoi c'est bête mais c'est
bien prise de tête en tout cas tout le
monde
c'est l'interview prise de tête ça c'est
galère gens seront pas déçus chez subway
est ce que vous êtes favorable à
l'adoption d'enfants par dés couples
homosexuels dans les corridas pourquoi
tant des corridas l'adoption les enfants
regroupés les sujets un peu bruyant
comme ça on va gagner 20 minutes la
manière
que ce soit des homosexuels pas des cons
c'est des cons et vous anthony camou
choc que des couples homosexuels
puissent adapter des enfants ça vous
choque pas écoutez c'est difficile d'y
répondre moi perso personnellement au
départ comme ça je suis contre si on
doit le dire pour ou contre je dirais
contre après il ya un grand débat là
dessus
est ce qu'un enfant sera plus malheureux
en maison de et enfin là d'un souhait ce
qui sera plus malheureux avec des
parents là on le sait pas mais après il
ya tout un débat mais c'est vrai que sur
le principe vous êtes content évidemment
tout le monde à dire la même chose il
vaut mieux avoir des parents homosexuels
sympa que des parents hétérosexuels
coincer un débat alors isild
l'avortement vous êtes pour ou contre
l'euthanasie la natation je te le dis
dans une centrale nucléaire
en gros toujours les sujets auxquels la
peine de mort j'imagine que vous êtes
contre la peine de mort comme nous tous
mais est-ce que vous êtes contre la
peine de mort pour les assassins
d'enfants
ben en fait par exemple
si c'est mon enfant que culé la peine de
mort où qu'il aille en prison pour moi
c'est pareil sauf si je veux tu mois
après que ce soit quelqu'un d'autre qui
le tue j'aurais envie de les tuer moi
mais à vous le feriez ses dépens les
dépens et circonstances mais sans doute
pas c'est un enfant qui a tué un autre
en soirée mais là ya pas de problème a
déjà notre enfant et sa muse qu'il faut
rater des prises de tête moi gbh échoue
en écoutant le bush pendant les ting
[Rires]
juge pas
j'ai beaucoup parlé bon alors atteint
une prise de tête
cette votre punition êtes vous favorable
au divorce
oui si ça ça me pose nue à la liberté
sexuelle dans le couple oui à
l'homosexualité à l'adoption d'enfants
par dés couples homosexuels à
l'avortement oui à l'euthanasie
ça semble peser au suicide si ça semble
poser si oui à la peine de mort pour les
assassins d'enfants
oui et est ce que vous êtes favorable
couloir de bus pas du tout
interview prise de tête
est ce que vous êtes favorable relations
sexuelles avant le mariage
c'est agréable mariage oui si les deux
personnes sont croissantes en faut pas
forcer les gens à se marier bien sûr non
je sais que oui oui oui
maintenant l'idée de la religion dans
une histoire d'amour j'ai encore du mal
à savoir pourquoi ça existe mais c'est
sacré le mariage ludivine c'est vrai et
j'ai pas encore pris conscience de la
sacralité de cet engagement à le voir il
va falloir je pense qu'on va falloir
sinon vous allez faire un mariage de
merde c'est vrai c'est vrai bien sûr
bien sûr à la mairie du 15e
est ce que vous êtes favorable à la
sexualité hors mariage favorable si
c'est vraiment un bon coup vous allez
pas de main morte là non je sais pas
j'avais pas mes conditions c'est un
mariage si c'est vous êtes marié votre
mari vous satisfait pas vraiment bon
imagine on vous demande réunion parce
que oui oui jusqu'ici tout va bien
imaginons c'est une vue de l'esprit oui
et vous êtes prête à le tromper avec le
premier bon coup venu bon bon coup c'est
pas toujours le premier venu oui pour
tester avant on est des fois ça peut
être le 23e favorable à la contraception
à l'avortement
puis l'amour à plusieurs
ben oui j'ai tout ça m'échappe
sabbatique
au divorce
balogh cto moins de 100 merde
ilan ramon suicide c'est bien c'est bien
mais ce succès aussi j'attends vers
l'euthanasie
oui mais oui oui faut tomber bien quand
même envie de me suicider vous déjà
ouais je pense que le losc côté de la
mort n'a envie d'aller voir le flop
le petit rien à voir mais j'ai réglé ou
de ton temps c'est toujours une
curiosité un tout à l'heure tu disais
que tu avais tout autant que ça soit
encore mais il y a plus peut arriver au
des moments de la vie où tir en très
grand danger
tu te dis tiens
ouais on est dans la merde ça va mal se
passer ça va finir mais en même temps il
peut-être que de l'autre côté il ya un
truc formidable qu'on a dit il ya une
dualité à ce moment là et c'est un
fantasme et qui peut être créatif aussi
ou mortelles favorables à l'euthanasie
oui on a même quand les gens vont bien
parce que là ça pose plus de problèmes
nous avons nos pages web j'avais des
prises de tête en bus pour vous je sais
pas j'ai pas l'impression que ce soit
encore super bien réglée éthiquement
parlant donc c'est un garde est pour
l'instant j'ai passé deux projets un
n'ont même pas vu dans le classement
vous êtes seule rame à la peine de mort
pas vraiment et la peine de mort pour
les assassins enfants pas plus
qu'est ce que vous lui avez vous dit
rien ce que vous en pensez ce ça dépend
des jours non non ça dépend des ges et
un jour où ou si j'imaginais con tu es
quelqu'un de proche de moi et c'est pas
quoi ouais j'aurais tendance à souhaiter
sa mort ou même essayé de la provoc et
moi même je pense mais sur la
philosophie tu crois que tant qu'on
n'est pas dans immédiatement immergé en
première ligne sinon à priori je pense
pas que la peine de mort résonne grand
chose si ce n'est de se débarrasser de
façon définitive de quelqu'un qui vous a
été hostile
ce qui n'est pas obligatoirement une
mauvaise manière non plus donc c'est ça
dépend des jours mais la nuit pour mardi
ou mercredi j'hésite jusqu'à midi je vis
vendredi je suis contre le dimanche
quand je m'emmerde vraiment je peux le
redevenir
est ce que vous êtes favorable à la
peine de mort pour ceux qui sont pour la
peine de mort n'est toujours pas au
droit de vote pour les immigrés ah oui
c'est important sont condamnés à mort
pour rester dans la thématique
bah oui c'est important que kiki qui est
un tout petit pouvoir de pour voter pour
des gens qui règlent leurs droits c'est
évidemment aussi non pourquoi le vote de
quelqu'un qui est là depuis six mois
qu'il n'a aucun intérêt commun avec toi
le problème c'est la communauté
d'intérêts qui donne le droit la
communauté de vote donc un immigrés qui
est là depuis un an ou deux ans à quai
dans un système auquel il est dans
lequel il est contraint de vivre comme
nous tous le vois pas pourquoi on ne
demanderait pas son avis sur des choses
tout à fait penser en fait tu es contre
le droit de vote pour les touristes
viennent
maintenant qu'il est je veux pas que roy
citer les flics la douane les urnes
ben non c'est tout faux que le maigre
est un peu est ce que vous êtes
favorable à la réouverture des maisons
closes
elles sont pas déjà ouvertes
ça va comme ça c'est aussi simple que ça
c'est le bordel recettes publicitaires
américains barrameda je trouve ça c'est
sans finalement d'accord ouais je sais
pas c'est dans le programme de quels
candidats savaient pas béraud et capote
au colza recevra la légalisation du
cannabis
plutôt way et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de 1h10 tube abonnez vous il
m'était impossible ou